it seemed like the centerpiece of every
celebrity tipping story is a photo of
the transaction receipt with the
celebrity's full name and account number
on it if we fake the receipt
there's a chance a nosy journalist could
verify the transaction and expose the
fraud so if we really wanted it to
appear real we'd have to use a bank cart
that was owned by someone with the same
name as our celebrity so I started
calling every michael richards listed in
the local white pages to ask for
permission to borrow their bank card for
a one-time transaction they'd be fully
reimbursed for and over the phone so
that you can charge my card ten thousand
dollars but unfortunately none of them
would help me out okay hello mr.
Richards for a moment I thought it was
all out of options but then it occurred
to me that if we could find someone who
is willing to temporarily change their
legal name to Michael Richards we'd be
able to open up a bank account on their
behalf and get the debit card we needed
to make the transaction real and after
posting several ads we finally got a
response what's your full name
Robert Paul Holmes sir can I ask why you
want to change your name
I've been Paul for a long time since I
was a kid I think probably five my
family started calling me by my middle
name and it just stuck so you just
wanted to be Paul huh yes okay for this
project I'm willing to pay you mmm to
change your name to Michael Richards
okay why we're trying to make it seem
like a man by that name left a big tip
at a restaurant okay and for that I'd be
willing to pay you $1,000
what's going through my brain right now
is the huge pain in the ass this is you
know and I'm thinking if a thousand
bucks is worth it I mean it's a yeah I'd
say oh can i counteroffer with some
money what amount do you feel
comfortable with for teens in my head I
like it
you can kind of offer with 12 whatever
man you know give me anything over a
thousand and now think that I went so
like a thousand and one dollar hmm you'd
be happy with that okay so should we do
a thousand one dollar sure yes I mean is
that as long as you're happy I just
wanna make sure you're happy with that
okay well it was great negotiating with
you yeah absolutely
I mean I'm using the go she ate her man
yeah great yeah thank you
absolutely after settling on an amount
that we're both happy with I had Paul
fill out the legal paperwork that was
required to begin the name change
process but that's when I realized we
had a big problem to complete a name
change in California you're legally
obligated to publicly announce the
change in a newspaper of general
circulation for four weeks in a row
if anyone suspected that the Michael
Richards tip was fake finding this name
change in the paper would be their
smoking gun
I tried calling my legal advisor Judge
Anthony Filosa to see if there was any
way around this you have to publish it
you can't just change your name secretly
[Music]
but unfortunately there wasn't so I felt
like the only way I could do this while
maintaining our secrecy was by creating
a newspaper that no one would ever read
my hope was that by calling it the
diarrhea Times no one would ever want to
pick it up but to ensure our publication
seemed legitimate to the courts I rented
us an office space in a media building
downtown and hired a professional ghost
writer named Austin Bowers who once
wrote me an entire book in less than a
week to serve as the papers
editor-in-chief you ever been the editor
of a newspaper before no this would be
the first time the paper would obviously
need content and it seemed like Austin
had a big vision I definitely want to
include lots topics
business arts politics draw lots of
people and they'll come they'll read
they'll share great just make sure
there's a section for name change
announcements okay right Boston walked
me through the rest of the paper which
included articles on entertainment
current events and even a section for
political cartoons that he drew himself
that supposed to be Donald Trump yes and
after including the name change
announcement in the bottom corner of
page three next to an op-ed about Zelda
Symphony the first issue was ready to
print
so you gonna start working on the next
issue yes okay so after receiving
thousands of copies back from the
printer we circulated our inaugural
issue of the diarrhea times to the
dozens of distribution partners we had
set up around LA County meeting the
minimum requirements to be recognized by
the courts as a legitimate publication
since California law dictates the name
change be published for four weeks in a
row over the next month Austin wrote
three more issues with the name change
announcement in each that were made
publicly available to LA residents so
with all the legal requirements now Matt
Robert Paul Holmes was given a date to
appear at the LA Superior Court house
where his name change to Michael
Richards was approved Here I am I am
officially Michael bushes which is weird
and again I'm not relating to it that
much but time will tell I guess
[Music]